privat kommen zu einem neuen video ist
hier mit max hintergrund haben wir einen
fernseher ihr kennt diese allgemeine
szenerie vielleicht sondern wir machen
heute eine versuche nicht zu lachen
gefärbtes wasser spezialfälle nicht
während wir uns die aktuelle youtube
kaka anschauen dafür keine kosten
gescheut und haben einfach was wir zu
tun haben aber die höheren anspruch auf
play wird hier das video erscheint und
dann geht's los doch erst zwei sachen
das video hinter uns ist von galil
erster linker effekten auf jeden fall
richtig geiler content und ist auch auf
youtube wahrscheinlich kennt in dem
video auch deswegen muss auch sagen das
ist explizit keine beleidigung oder
keine lustig machen über die youtube
sondern ein lustiges zusammenschneiden
ihrer videos jetzt aber das hat mich so
kommen
[Gelächter]
ich denke zug wird aber endlich zu
machen
[Gelächter]
liebe leute wir sind auf jeden fall
schon schwer gezeichnet als meine beine
sind blau
rabbi capri meine beine sind blau
erinnert ist eine automatik warten
konkurrenten angebot auch gut dass wir
laufen ja das muss man dann weiß man wie
groß ist die kraft wie sie sabotieren
euro erwachsene wünschen leute direkt in
der kamera ist eine glaswand und da
kommt das wohnzimmer und unsere mutter
gerade besuchen erwachsene menschen
wir sehen ja hat die waldmeister mich
stolz weil ich bin
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was wichtig ist
[Gelächter]